Speaker 1: Let's speak to some people from the
audience. I want to hear from the people. We do
this via discord. You can find The David Pakman
Show discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Why don't we start today with faith from
Southern California? Faith, you are on the air.
Speaker 5: OK, David, can you hear me? Am I going
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine. Faith.
Speaker 5: Why it was so good to
talk to you likewise. My question is,
so I'm kind of sick of the politicians and
it's been infrastructure week forever. Yeah,
I kind of want to bypass all the that's the stuff
I'm a nursing home administrator at. This pandemic
has been hell on us and our kiddos. I say kiddo's,
but anybody who is disabled and in a nursing home
has very little resources and they've been stuck
inside and isolated, unfortunately. And well,
conna, someone who's been on your show and
you've spoken to is about as as has called
me and I have an infrastructure proposal and
I wanted to see what your thoughts on it are
here in Southern California. We have one
hundred and sixteen community colleges.
All of them have child care on campus. And
it's great for students, the community,
and it's great for building job experience for
the first students on campus. If we could build
adult day care on campuses, that would be
something that is such a big need to be filled.
Is that something you've ever heard of, Faith?
Speaker 1: I've got I've not heard of it,
but I love the idea. And it's similar
to the idea of postal banking. Let's
create the the the possibility of banking at
the post office so that people who were unbanked
or maybe live in places where there a post office,
but no bank would have readier access to banking
services. I love that type of idea of thinking
outside the box in that way. I don't know exactly
how it gets carried out and jurisdictionally
and from a regulatory standpoint, those
complications. But yes, faith a very good idea.
Speaker 5: Thank you. And so we're trying to push
it with for the national infrastructure because
it's been infrastructure weak forever. Yeah,
so a few people with disabilities in mind, you
know, a great advocate. I love your show. If
you could continue to advocate for people with
disabilities and their family, they're so isolated
and it sucks because they're the people with the
biggest hearts. And if I find that in California,
we have these community colleges with child care
on campus, if we can get a dependent care on
campus, I imagine that on a national scale, this
community would be so much more supported and less
isolated, creating jobs and creating opportunity.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very much. I
appreciate the suggestion. Thank you very much.
There is faith with really a great idea. It's a
it's a very, very interesting idea. Let's go next
to Toby from Kansas. Toby, you're on the air.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. I called about a month
ago and I had a neighbor call me in the middle of
our school that I had to dash out. So I just want
to apologize for that. My question is surrounding
the conversation you have with destiny about
student loan cancelation. I was wondering
what your final position was. Are you more
of a you do want universal cancelation or are
you looking for more of a bottom up approach
Speaker 1: where Michael Sam Ceder recently had
a conversation with Destiny about that? Which
conversation of mine are you referring to?
Speaker 4: Oh, I was referring to your post
discussion. I think you guys had a
quick sum up, didn't you? And you
guys were talking about whether it should be.
Speaker 1: Oh, I don't think we touched it. I
don't think we talked about that at all. No, I've
talked before. I am not understanding the case for
full student loan cancelation period flat out. The
impact of it is not clear to me would actually be
progressive. And I'm not sure what
the justification is just for saying
pay everybody's debt period altogether. So no, I.
But but no, I didn't talk about that with Destiny
after that. I did talk to Destiny recently after
his Sam Ceder thing, but we didn't really talk
about the student loan stuff. Now, Toby, I
have to ask, are you originally from Kansas?
Speaker 4: No, I actually moved here
about eight years ago from the UK.
Speaker 1: That's making sense, you know, because
you didn't I mean, I've only been to Kansas once,
but I didn't hear people with your accent there.
Speaker 4: No, definitely not. I'm in the I'm
in a college town, so it's a lot less a lot
more left leaning than the rest of Kansas.
I see. It's definitely, definitely,
definitely different in the UK,
Speaker 1: that's for sure. That's for sure. All
right, Toby, thank you. I appreciate the call.
Speaker 4: I did have one more thing I just
wanted to say. Is your family back in Argentina
happy for Lionel Messi for winning the
Copa America, or is he like some other
Argentineans, as I understand that they kind of
prioritize Maradona's success. And, you know,
Speaker 1: everybody in my family is very
pleased with with Massie's victory. Yeah.
Speaker 4: All right, well, that brings
joy to my heart, and I hope you have one.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much. I appreciate
that. Yeah. Big victory in the Copa America for
Argentina. It was an incredible it was an historic
day. I think I would I would even venture to say